I was in Phoenix and, um,
Calen was doing a show there. I went there just so's, you know,
Calen was doing a show there and I went on
stage. I went, I connected with the radio station and I went on stage.
They said it was cool. And I interrupted his show. That's Brian Callan.
A lot of you guys probably don't know who he is. Okay.
Cause he's a young comic coming up 52
and starting to look. It's all good. Callan. You starting to look like politics.
It's all good. Yeah. You start to look like a politician.
You start to look like an actor playing politician. It's all good. Yar.
It's all good. We are.
And um,
I went to go do that and I,
I went in and there's footage. We'll release it later, but
it was, I don't even want to say too much about it, but man,
let me just tell you this.
It was so amazing to do
that and share that moment with him. Like he's one of my best friends, you know,
and to see the look on his face, like the pure, what the,
but joy, but like, why are you here? And then we started roasting each other,
just being silly. I was out there for maybe eight minutes.
I let them do the rest of the day. Obviously I'm not going to just take it.
I should have sent them off and just been like, I'll do my. Uh,
but uh, yeah, it was so funny, dude. He,
they were in the middle of it. He says, Hey man, what the are you doing?
Doing hair? And I started laughing, dude. He wore a gray shirt,
dude. It's so funny. It was so funny, dude. Here's the other thing too.
Don't ever wear a gray shirt when you're performing. No. Why?
A lot of falls under your armpits now. Kalin. Why weren't you sweating?
It's either because you weren't working hard or you got Botox shot in yarn pits.
Now one time, a big, big comedian told me that that's what he did.
And I thought it was gross. And I thought, wow, that's gross. And he said, yeah,
but you don't get sweaty pits. And I thought, but you man,
why would you want to not get sweaty pits a man?
And I thought maybe I should do that. And he said, you should do it. And I said,
yeah, even though I knew well,
shore would never do it because man
something, man, when I was a kid, I used to look. I had a buddy who had that,
got that upper lip, sweat. You know, guys will get that upper lip. Sweat.
What the is that? Dude?
Just beads of sweat above your top lip. Hey man,
it's not hot there. Hey dude, it's hot in your armpits,
in your and on your feet. And if it's hot on your upper lip,
figure it out. Don't go outside. Always have ice on you. Okay.
Man, dude, I forgot.
Get his name, but he always had upper lip sweat and I would look at that, dude.
You think I wouldn't look at that. You think I wouldn't look at that.
I would try. Even as a kid to look at that while he was talking,
I would try to even look at that while he was talking, knowing well,
he might catch me, but that's what I was a kid dude.
That's how much I didn't give a. Even as a five-year-olds
so rude. Um, but yeah, I did that. That's the kind of kid I was dude.
That's the kind of kid I was. And one time I saw Doug,
whatever his name was. Oh man. One time I saw a kid doing the monkey bars.
Hey children's playgrounds make them safer.
Actually, I haven't been on a children's playground in a long time.
I got to go and just not be creepy.
I just got to go chill out and look and like a hoodie.
I would feel creepy even being in one right now. But, but uh,
going to a children's playground when you,
Oh my God, they used to be,
it used to be like go running through a children's playground.
Used to be like going through a gauntlet. I mean, dude, everything was iron.
Seesaws were, you'd go.
So high and then you'd get the stronger guy on the other side and he would kick
up and then your, uh,
but would just slam into the ground with no cush.
And it would just like shorten your spine.
I'm probably supposed to be six foot five, except for say seesaws.
Also what is called a Seesaw, you know? Um,
and then there were monkey bars who dug, what the was his last name? Doug,
something like Conrad.
Doug something, correct.
Doug something. Anyway, he looked so much like a Doug.
He was skinny and he.
Was cool. I liked him. He came over once or twice and that's,
it really didn't work out, you know? But uh,
he was doing the monkey bars and he was standing on the top rung of the monkey
bar, you know, the, the latter part. And he was just chilling. And I was,
I was on the monkey bars like this,
just holding it as a five-year-old how old must've I been eight just holding
it, watching Doug.
And he was standing on it and he lost his foot grip and his feet just went funk
and it went blank and his taint smash on the upper rung of the
ladder. And he goes, And dude,
he couldn't speak. And I was just like this, looking at him. And I thought,
Oh no, he immediately started crying. And then I was like, are you, I was like,
are you okay? And then he just ran to a teacher. That
I would have to. No, I hope he's okay. He's probably okay though. But,
but it eat. His tank. Got the up dude.
When his taint hit the I thought.
And then.
It was just, it was so brutal. I literally thought, Oh,
his balls exploded as a kid. I was just like this. His balls exploded.
that. That's not even fun, dude.
You don't want to do to my kid when he wants to go on the monkey bars,
I go like this, get down, get down, dude, get down. And he'd be like, why not?
Because it's not fun. Dude. Think about what you're doing. But I like to cry.
I like to cross it. It's like, Whoa, just walk across,
walk across on the bottom. It's fine.
Walk on the ground from one end to the other, but let twos my hands. Why?
Think about, why do Dominic?
I'm going to murder my kid with logic for real. I'm 39.
What are you going to argue with me? I know about all this. Yeah,
but I like to do that and know my friends do that.
So if they jumped off a bridge, what would you do? I dunno.
Would you jump off a bridge now? All right, cool. So what's up now, dude?
Why crawling across your hands? I thought it was fun, but I guess that's not.
Yeah. You're right now. You're right now. Okay.
What do you want to do? Let's get ice cream.
No. Why not? You tell me
Because they only eat after dinner, like late at night,
because that's when you want it the most that's right. Because why?
Because you said that's the right thing. That's the right time to ice cream.
Rephrase that because that's the right time to eat ice cream.
Yes. Good boy. Now let's go to the gym. That I'm six.
Oh dude.
dude.
That I want to wear shorts. That's fine. But also put on a shirt.
You can't have long sleeves and shorts. You look indecisive. Okay.
Yeah.
Man. My, my kid is going to be like, the other kids are going to be like,
they're going to think about it. They're going to,
my kid's going to be like saying to the other kids.
And they're going to be like, who the is that? Like as a, like a, his home?
What the heck I, sorry, I can't go into monkey bars. Why?
Because you could just walk across on the bottom. Yeah. But that takes off.
That takes away the whole fun of it. No. Why? Think about it.
Well, I like to use my hands. Why? Because it's fun to use the hands.
Cause you're in the air a little bit. I guess that's actually enough.
I'll nevermind. They're just all boring kids.
Cause of me just like getting calls from other parents.
Hello? Hey. Hi. Is this Chris? D'Elia? Yeah.
Hi. Yeah. So, um.
Tommy came home and he, he had,
I don't know how to say this,
but he told your kid told him that he's not allowed to do the monkey bars.
Cause it's not fun. And that was your way. That was your rule. Yeah.
Okay. So, um,
I don't think that that's cool that your kid is telling my kid not to do on the
playground and that is coming from you.
Really? Yeah. Why? Well,
because my kid likes to do the money.
Keep ours. Well can't you just do it walking across from the bottom.
Okay.
Yeah. I don't know. Look,
he's just supposed to do what he wants to think about that.
The monkey bars and then break it down. Why is it fun? Why?
Cause you're in the air because you're higher up. Yeah, no I understand.
But doesn't that you're three feet above the ground. If that's fun to you,
then you're a piece of. That's like nothing different.
I mean, I guess you're right. It's just three feet.
[inaudible] if you'd like to make a call, please hang up and try again.
Message C too.
And then just me eat an ice cream with my kid at 11.
Yeah,
it does taste good on this time.
Well, it does taste good at this time. Make sure you eat too much.
Make sure you eat too much.
So your legs start until you get restless leg syndrome like daddy, ah,
And then you can't sleep. Then you gotta to wake up or some for school,
even though you shouldn't have to go to school. Ha I never wanted it to go.
Whatever dude, them kids, man. They don't know. Mine's going to know so much.
You know, it's fine, dude. I don't know. But just.